-Our next guests are
entertainment icons
who have been married
for over 40 years.
She's an award-winning
actress, author, and activist,
and he is a talk show legend
New episodes of their
podcast "Double Date"
are available Mondays.
Please welcome to the show
Phil Donahue and Marlo Thomas.
Thank you both so much
for being here.
-Hi, hi.
-Hi.
Seth! I've never
been up this late.
-Well, I'm very
honored to have you.
And you know, I wish I had
all my guests in studio,
but Phil, this would have
been extra special.
You used to film
your show in this studio.
Do you have fond memories of 8G?
-Well, have you noticed my ghost
wandering around there?
-Yeah. We've never seen a ghos
with such a long mic cord.
-Right. Right. No kidding.
That was the early days.
I used to run to
the back of the audience
and strangle three people
in the front row.
That was before
the wireless mic.
-Well, obviously
hosting a talk show
paid off as well for you, Phil
specifically with Marlo.
I did not realize you guys hav
been together for 41 years
and you met, Marlo, when you
were a guest on Phil's show.
-Yeah. Yeah. It was kind o
love at first sight.
Or something.
Something chemical happened.
He came into the green roo
and I had not seen his show,
'cause it wasn't
in L.A. at the time.
And so he came in,
and it was like one of those
shampoo commercials, you know?
The white hair and the blu
eyes, the whole Irish thing.
I got very interested in him
and he looked at me and said -
[ Chuckles ] --
-Well, I thought she was
a bad thought, you know?
If you're Catholic, you
understand what that means
-[ Laughing ]
-And one thing led to anothe
and before you know it,
we were a real, live couple.
-But I read that
you met your wife
and you fell in love
at first sight.
-That is the way
I agreed to tell it.
-[ Laughing ]
No, but I mean, that's --
-It is true, though.
We met at a wedding
and the last thing
I think either of us
were looking for was that,
and yet we're together
ever since then,
so it is amazing
how fortuitous it can be.
-And a lot of people
that we interview for
the podcast, that was so.
Billy Crystal was like 18.
He was playing ball on the beach
and this girl in
a pink bikini walked by
and he, like,
fell in love with her,
and they've been married,
like, 60 years.
So that does happen.
-The first vision --
Malcolm Gladwell made this
a part of American culture
really.
The first look at a person
is the most important one.
That's when -- well, we foun
in the interviews we did
with couples for our book,
many of those couples
fell in love on the first date
the first look,
the first anything.
-And I was doing his show,
so it was kind of bare,
because we'd never met before,
and all of the sudden
we were flirting like mad,
and his show was
one person for an hour,
and you know, I'm going,
"Oh, Phil.
You're so funny, Phil."
It was just really embarrassing,
but it happens,
and I'm sure you felt that
when you met Alexi.
-I did. I want to ask, because
I will say the next day --
you know,
we met Friday of a wedding
and the wedding on Saturday --
true stories, people were coming
up and asking my wife and I,
who had just met,
how long we'd been a couple.
So it was chemistry right away
but I'm wondering --
you guys knew you were flirting,
but friends of yours who
watched that TV appearance
did they recognize it as well?
-Everybody.
-Yeah.
-Everybody called me and said,
"What was that about?"
I mean, it wasn't
my first talk show, right?
I'd been interviewed by
Johnny Carson
and all other people.
I'd never fallen for anybody
on their show before.
It was just --
and the woman that lived
next door to you came over
and she said that to you.
She said,
"What did you do today?
-Yeah. Well. You know, "Wh
was that you had on today?
So you know,
I guess it was obvious.
We didn't think so at the time
We weren't thinking about that
-But he called me the next day
and then we went out to dinner
That was it.
-Ta-da.
-Ta-da. There you are.
-You guys were
pretty private early on.
I mean, for being a couple
that had a profile,
you know, each of you
were well-known.
You were not very public about
your relationship, correct
-No, we haven't been.
And we made the decision early
because we got married quietly
in my parents' house
and then we took off
for our honeymoon.
And so when we got back,
we were being asked to
co-host the Emmys together
and co-host, what was it,
the People's Choice,
and "People" magazine and
it was kind of alarming.
We said to each other,
"Let's back off from this,
'cause if we do this,
we're putting it out there
like a product, and they'l
just take shots at it,
so let's be quiet."
So we did. We kept our
marriage out of the limelight.
We didn't do anything together
But then after being married
like, about 39 years,
we thought,
"Well, they can't hurt us now.
What are they gonna say?"
-They say, wait 40 years, and if
you're still happily married
do a podcast.
-But it was fun,
because there we were
for the first time,
talking about our marriage
on these double dates
with these other people,
and it was a new experience.
And Phil had said to me
when we were starting
to go out around the country
to interview the couples,
he said, "I'm not talking
about our marriage."
I said, "Okay."
When you're married 40 years
you know what to say, right?
I said, "No problem."
But once we got there, you did
because it was a conversation.
-Yeah, if I said
anything about us,
it seemed to
blow the doors open.
The other couple would --
I mean, it's like we couldn'
get them to stop talking.
I think there's
a message there somewhere --
four people are
more likely to say things
that are more intimate
than two people.
-Than a reporter would get
A lot of people who
interviewed us afterward
from newspapers and magazine
and stuff said,
"How did you get them to
talk about these things?
I could never have gotten that."
I said, "Well, you're a
reporter, and we're not.
We're a couple."
-[ Chuckles ] Right.
-So we're sitting down
with another couple
over a glass of wine
and talking.
It doesn't have
that scary feeling
that you're going to
be misquoted
and somebody's out to get you.
We didn't have any of that
-Based on the people
you've talked to,
are there any main takeaways
Any keys that you feel
you've discovered
about a healthy relationship
-I think in many ways,
we discovered things that
we should have already known
but first of all, it takes both.
You can't have one person
committed to the relationshi
and the other person
like baggage that has
to be dragged along.
That wears out the person
who's for the union,
and the other one who isn't.
-So all of these
long-married couples,
they all had
this thing in common,
which is they both really
wanted it, whatever it was
Kyra Sedgwick said there can b
no Plan B when you get married
This is it.
And they go to
marriage counseling --
not Kyra Sedgwick,
but many of the couples
went to marriage counseling.
-Yeah, I think that is the
ultimate, I think, evidenc
of a good marriage.
I mean, if people
are voluntarily
committed to marriage
counseling,
that means you really care
-We've never been to one,
because Mr. Irish here
would rather die
than talk about himself.
-He'll go if
it's court-appointed,
but he's not going voluntarily
-Right.
-You guys, thank you so much
both for doing the podcast
and for spending time
with me today.
I really appreciate it.
-Thank you, Seth.
-Good luck on your marriage.
-Thank you.
-New episodes of "Double Date"
are available Mondays.